I am using immune stimulation programs to help the immune system. Is there any other program to increase immunity?
Um, no, I don't think so. So you increase your your what is immunity? First of all, so let's define our terms.
So I want to increase my immunity. What does I mean? You want to increase your white blood cell count?
You want to increase your lymphocyte account? You want to increase your nutritional account?
So increasing a count, increasing a count of lymphocytes. Can I do that by writing the right program?
No, I don't think so. Um, what increases your immune system? While your immune system will increase,
um, will make more immune cells in the event that there's a pathogen attack? So I get an infection,
I have more white blood cells. That's what you measure the complete blood count on a blood test.
It has a normal range. So let's say the normal range of white blood cells has four, if you look at a
blood test, it'll say four to 11 or something like that. But really, the normal range of white blood cell
count is like four to six point five, maybe. And while I want my white blood cell count higher,
because then that will help me kill off more pathogens. No, there's a normal range. You know, we
always think that, you know, we're Americans. So if this much is good for me, then twice as much
for me, really good for me. That's just how it works. Um, there's a, if my white blood cell count is low,
there's a reason. It's not because I need to stimulate it. There's a reason why my white blood cell count
is also, let's say I do a complete blood count. And my white blood cell count is 2.5 percent. That's
really low. Oh my gosh, I need to build it up. I'm gonna take some immune supplements. I'm gonna
do this. Well, yes, that would be good. But there's a reason why it's low. We have to find the reason.
We got to ask why, okay? So why is it low? Well, it could be low because I, you know, I'm fighting
a disease. So it could be low because I'm fighting cancer and my immune system is fatigue. So what do I
do? Well, you then that would be I'm going to take immune supplements to help fight this disease. I'm
going to try to get rest. I'm going to try to eat correctly. How do my body make these immune
cells? They make it through protein. It might protein deficient in my diet. I need to be eating more
protein. There's all sorts of reasons why. But so when you look as a practitioner at a complete
blood count, it helps you with differential diagnosis of what the problem is. If the person
doesn't have a diagnosis of cancer, or their cancer is in relative state of remission,
but they have a suppressed white blood cell count, beating below 3.5, let's say,
chronically, then you have to think of does this person have a chronic viral infection? A chronic
infection, like they have with this chronic Lyme disease or something, or chronic Epstein bar virus.
That could give that could express itself at a complete blood count as a suppressed white blood cell
count. So just taking a whole bunch of immune stimulants is not necessarily the way you would treat that.
You would need to do some further investigation to find out why. So if I have an autoimmune patient,
a chronically ill patient come to me. They don't have cancer. They just don't feel good. And we do
CBC with differential and they have a suppressed white blood cell count. It's a pretty good chance,
especially if you look at past blood tests. And it's been suppressed for the last three years,
that this person is dealing with a chronic infection. Then it's time to do some other antibody tests,
some pathogen antibody tests. Does this person have a chronic Epstein bar? They have an IGM
elevated antibody on Epstein bar virus. That means they have a current Epstein bar virus that they
probably had for years this current infection of Epstein bar. Then you need to treat the Epstein bar.
So how would you get the, it's not a matter of manipulating the white blood cell count. You want to get
the person better so that the white blood cell count is an expression of their illness. Treat the illness.
So the white blood cell count will balance itself out. So now you start doing the right
machine. Say the person has a right machine. You're running Epstein bar frequencies of that person.
And then you're killing the Epstein bar and you look at a CBC again and you see that white blood cell
count go up and the person symptoms start to go down and they start feeling better. Oh my gosh,
you were just different. I'm a doctor. He just asked the right questions. So you're not going to
get the right answers. You don't ask the right questions. So don't look at blood tests as I need to get
these back into range. What supplement can I take to get this back in range? That's a, that's a
medicinal way to look at something. That's not the way we want to look at things. We want to look at
holistically. If I have something out of range, I want to go, why is it out of range? It's just
a sign. It's just like a beacon that's flashing telling me there's something wrong.
I, if I have a beacon flashing telling me there's something wrong, I could deal with it one of two
ways. I could figure out why is that beacon is flashing and fix that so the beacon stops flashing
or I could just take up my pistol and shoot a 22 into the beacon. So it stops flashing.
Now I've solved it. That's kind of the medicinal way to look at things. My cholesterol is high,
so I'm going to take lipitor. Oh, my cholesterol is normal now. Oh, you did is figure out a drug that
would lower cholesterol. You didn't solve why the cholesterol was high. So we don't want to use
natural beads to do the same thing. We don't want to say, oh, my white blood cell count is low.
Is there some magic supplement that's going to raise my white blood cell count?
If there was, that wouldn't be the right approach. Is there a right problem that will increase my
white blood cell count? I'm not trying to be facetious to the person asking the question. I think we all
have these questions. We all just want to solve our problems, but we can't solve our problems by just
by not digging into finding out what the problem, why the problems there in the first place.
So if I want to, if this person said, I didn't even look at my, I don't know, he's talking about
whether it's a complete blood cell. I just want to increase my immunity so I don't get sick.
Well, how we increase our immunity so we don't get sick is we want to be exposed to pathogens.
It's the worst thing you could do is not be exposed to everyday pathogens because that's what actually
builds your immune system. So the definition of a healthy immune system is what I have
circulated antibodies against a lot of different pathogens because I was exposed to strep because my
little kid came home with strep and I was exposed to strep and I fired a TH water response and a TH2
response which is a B cell response which made antibodies against strep. How I have circulated
antibodies against streps and how I go to work and somebody else had strep. I don't get sick at all,
but through my co-workers are sick. But I didn't get sick because I've been exposed to these things.
We don't shelter ourselves and wash our hands with anti-bacterial soap and wear masks and do all these
foolish things that we're going to not be exposed to pathogens. You actually want to be exposed to
pathogens so that your immune system ex-antibodies against said pathogens and now you have circulated
antibodies against multiple different pathogens that will keep you from getting sick. That's
what a healthy immune system is. And what I have issues with blood tests when I have objective
signs or subjective symptoms that is making me feel ill, you want to always dig to reasons why
and then you fix that reason why and then the objective side will improve and the subjective
symptoms will improve. So thank you too much for this question but I hope that helps.